1923 is shrouded in secrecy but all the
Yellowstone fans waiting for a glimpse
into the latest installment to the
Dutton family Saga here's everything we
know so far according to the Hollywood
Reporter 1923 was commissioned following
the success of both Yellowstone and
1883. all by confirming that Paramount
plus sees Taylor Sheridan's tapestry of
family and power as a flagship franchise
[Music]
that land is a mine
no one can sell it but me thr had
previously suggested that 1883 would
receive an additional batch of episodes
but Sheridan has since corrected the
record clarifying to deadline we wanted
to make a 10-hour movie that ended and
that's what we did in 1923 we'll see the
early years of the 20th century throw
life-altering curveballs at the Dutton
family the series promises to be an
insightful look at Yellowstone ranch's
humble beginnings Taylor Sheridan's 1923
will debut on December 18 2022 on
Paramount Plus in the U.S and Canada
viewers in the UK and Australia can
catch the episode on December 19th
there's a rawness to the West that still
reflects where we came from the premiere
will also run on Cable's Paramount
Network immediately following episode 7
of the latest season of Yellowstone the
second episode of 1923 will hit the
Paramount Network on January 1st 2023.
it remains to be seen at the rest of
1923 will air on the cable channel 1923
will consist of Eight Episodes and is
expected to run for two seasons it's not
known if both seasons will take place in
1923 or if there will be a time Jump
like Yellowstone in 1883 Taylor
Sheridan's upcoming prequel series will
focus on the infamous Dutton family as
they continue to expand their reach and
Power in the state of Montana you know
the first is to settle this Valley
fighting was all they knew that's how
they got here how they kept the land
once they did this time the Dutton
ancestors include Jacob Dutton the
grizzled old patriarch of the
Yellowstone Ranch Jacob is the brother
of James who was played by Tim McGraw in
1883. Jacob Dutton is joined on screen
by his loyal headstrong wife Kara 1923
explores the early days of the
Yellowstone making it abundantly clear
that John Dutton III in his family have
it easy compared to the challenges their
ancestors faced viewers will experience
some of the 20th Century's key events
Through The Eyes of the duttons an
official plot synopsis confirmed that
the series will explore the early 20th
century when pandemics historic drought
the end of prohibition and the Great
Depression all plagued the Mountain West
and the duttons who call it home 1923
will be the most star-studded Series in
the Yellowstone Universe to date ever
wonder what this place looked like
before any of us were here
the show is led by Harrison Ford who is
making his television debut as Jacob
Dutton and a Vanity Fair interview Ford
described Jacob as a man who has no
choice but to focus on Survival Ford
went on to describe the Dutton struggle
saying they can lose it all on a season
they're up against weather the economy
the influx of railroads and the change
in the cattle business everything is
heart fought for an embarrassment we are
the sacrifice it took to give us a home
hello mirin plays Cara Dutton Jacob's
wife by all accounts the two seem to
still be in love even after 40 years of
marriage but while Jacob is the
archetype of the All-American Cowboy
Kara is more nuanced mirin's Cara speaks
with an Irish accent she told Vanity
Fair I see Cara as an immigrant other
1923 cast members include Supernatural
actor Sebastian Roche as father Ronald
the principal of a Native American
school The Departed actor James badge
Dale plays Jacob's right-hand man John
Dutton senior John's wife Emma is played
by Marley Shelton last seen in 2022
screen Robert Patrick who recently
played the white dragon in Peacemaker
role play Sheriff William McDowell and
rounding out the cast as Timothy Dalton
as Donald Whitfield playing a character
described only as intimidating and
nefarious there's a brief teaser trailer
for 1923 that clocks in at just under 30
seconds this first look at the series
paints early 20th century Montana is an
unforgiving State the trailer kicks off
with an unidentified female narrator
saying violence is always home to this
family she goes on to say that violence
has followed the Dutton family all the
way from the Scottish Highlands and the
slums of Dublin a young man is seen
fallen off his horse reaching for a gun
then soldiers fill the screen making it
clear that war will feature in the story
World War one ended five years earlier
in 1918 but was surely not far from the
memories of its veterans 1883 fans will
remember Tom hanks's cameo in a civil
war flashback on that show eures catch a
glimpse of a dower Jacob Dutton on
Horseback and more battle scenes are
intercut with shots of Jacob wearing a
sheriff's star and the rest of the
Dutton Clan together Helen mirren's Cara
Dutton is a fighter too she seemed
bloodied pointing shotgun at someone
cowering on the ground from the looks of
things 1923 is going to be just as
suspenseful and action-packed as 1883
and true Taylor Sheridan Style
those who want to catch up on Taylor
Sheridan's Yellowstone franchise before
the debut of 1923 may need to subscribe
to a variety of streaming services
Yellowstone the heart of the franchise
is currently airing its fifth season on
Paramount network with new episodes
released weekly in the U.S seasons one
through four can be watched on peacock
viewers who want to stream season 5 can
do so via the Paramount Network fans can
also catch up on the series via DirecTV
if you want to catch all those
lighthearted Beth moments we all love I
believe in love him with your whole soul
and destroying anything
that wants to kill what you love
Canada seasons one through four of
Yellowstone are available to stream on
Amazon Prime video and season 5 episodes
are released weekly all five seasons of
Yellowstone are available on Paramount
Plus in the United Kingdom viewers from
around the world can also purchase
individual Seasons through their
favorite Digital Services like Apple TV
the Google Play Store and Amazon 1883 is
available to stream on Paramount plus
wherever the service is available
including the US Canada and the UK and
now is a perfect time to catch up on the
drama before 1923 arrives
[Music]
foreign
[Music]